flug einer lieben freundin ich glaube
jeder von euch kennen kann
online gegen andere leute quiz spielen
und drei fanpages von mir haben sich die
mühe gemacht und quiz für mich erstellt
also dass
chris für evolution spray das ist das
erste quits also 3 2
1 los geht's wie viele kalorien hat ein
problem
[Musik]
opel hat keine kalorien
was macht ihr mal nancy china und robin
bei mir im quiz jetzt wenn ich das jetzt
mit irgendwelchen anderen leuten spielt
bei einer erneuten wenn wir fragen frage
nummer zwei wie heißt der hahn auf der
klubs packung
ich glaube dass das scherzfrage hess 11
frage 3 wie viele tage ihres lebens
verbrauchen frauen durchschnittlich um
etwas in ihrer handtasche zu suchen ok
also meine freude
es ist nicht mehr wie viele tage im
leben brauchen um etwas suchen 11.06
frauen brauchen 74 tage im jahr nur wenn
etwas in ihrer handtasche zu suchen
fragen oder vier von acht wie oft ein
mensch vor wenn da jetzt ein bild von
mir ist mit dem kurzen acht perfekt ich
würde sagen
5700 mal
[Musik]
wieder weil jetzt gewinne ich es elf
gegen die anderen guck mal hier platz
drei
frage nummer fünf von acht wie viele
samenkörner befinden sich
durchschnittlich auf einem mcdonalds
burger auf das habe ich aber
wo habt ihr diese bilder her was auf
zeit und daher
wie lange dauerte der dreißigjährige
krieg
60 jahre
[Musik]
sind ist dass sandra da oben im panzer
vorletzte frage wahr oder falsch
kleopatra stammte aus ägypten das ist
[Musik]
mona ich hasse dich so doll monats
fanpage übrigens punkt nerds also folgte
gern auf instagram ich würde sagen
kleopatra stammte safe aus ägypten
wahrscheinlich kommt ja aus köln letzte
frage im ersten kurs wie viel prozent
der menschen staubsaugen in unterwäsche
das ist aus dem topf
staubsauger unterwäsche ich nicht viel
sagen 4 prozent
[Musik]
er hatte zwei platz seine 200 verdammt
das ultimative laser luca quiz das hier
ist chris nummer zwei von drei auch los
ich muss nicht mal ein bisschen
schneller sein los geht's vor was hat
luca am meisten angst okay es geht also
mich er hat perfekt er von nichts und
orange bin spiele ich bin ich bin würde
ich sagen wir spielen auch schon aber
spenden
zweite frage mehrfachauswahl wie viele
gehirnzellen hat luca ok 0 keine genauso
viele wie arbeit stoppen hat also null
oder 0 okay
[Musik]
das ist nicht witzig auch wenn ich
gerade mache wie lange braucht luca auf
der toilette
okay nicht länger als fünf minuten 20
minuten die toilette ist ein zweites
zuhause
ich will jetzt mein zweites zuhause
schönes bild auch übrigens das quiz tier
ist bei dabei von jesse also auf in
stuck on unterstrich logi schaut auch
bei ihr gern vorbei frage nummer vier
aus welchem land stammt der name luca
aus italien der meine eltern perfekt
[Musik]
wo hatte nie diese bilder heraus frage
nummer fünf in welchem jahr hatte luca
diese tolle frisur oh gott was kommt
jetzt
[Musik]
wie viele aufrufe hat sein
erfolgreichstes tik tok
20,3 millionen
[Musik]
ich weiß auch nicht warum fragen über 7
wie groß ist luca
ich könnte euch ins gesicht kotzen frage
nummer 8 zu welchem gemüse hat luca
ähnlichkeit
[Musik]
vorletzte frage lukas lieblingsfarbe ist
gelb die schwarz und gelb genommen
schwarz und gelb ich bin kein großer
doggen fan aber ich liebe die
kombination genauso wie ein auto das
bild habe ich auch auf in seinem
hochladen ich hoffe ihr habt schon
gelegt letzte frage wie viele käsesorten
waren auf der letzten pizza 7
jetzt nicht auf dem ersten platz
ich war zum gründer von kartonpackungen
seine mülltonne vor der haustür auf
platz drei haben wir china wieder am
ohne grenzen ist
zweiter bin
[Musik]
das setzte quilts hat mir die liebe
berlin gemacht und zwar ist es eine
schätzfrage quiz berlin heißt auf
install ogi unterstrichen der
unterstrich lauch also jetzt meine
lieben freunde wir müssen schätzen erste
frage wie lange ist ein neugeborener
blauwal in meta ein neugeborener blau
weil ich würde mal sagen drei meter
sonderklasse
wo kommt der aus zweite frage wieviel km
h hat eine regentropfen
[Musik]
bruder wie bist du auf diese frage
gekommen frage drei von zehn wie viel
liter bier werden in deutschland pro
kopf jährlich getrunken bei sandra würde
ich sagen 4000 liter pro jahr auf den
typischen deutschen rechner will ich
sagen 64
100 liter
was frage nummer vier wie viele
einkerbungen hat ein golfball auch ich
war heute geholfen habt ihr vielleicht
auch auf instagram gesehen
ein golfball hat einkerbungen in menge
von 178
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie schwer kann eine schönwetter wolke
werden schönwetterwolken passt doch ich
würde sagen eine tonne vielleicht
schönwetter
wie viele zähne hat ein eisbär
32 42 52 62 wird kriegt einfach irgendwo
[Musik]
ich sollte sie da so machen die nase
eines menschen hat ca 5 millionen geruch
zählen wie viele hat die nase eines
dackels ich glaube runde haben extrem
viele geruch zellen von der ich wollte
ja so
[Musik]
das für eine taktik besonderes abi
gewesen letzte frage wie lange wartet
ein durchschnittlicher bundesbürger in
seinem gesamten leben an der roten ampel
ich sag 14 tage ich habe jetzt nicht mit
der taktik ich habe oft wie schwer ist
unsere erde ich weiß es 5,9 75 millionen
allerdings kommen nur schon zur letzten
frage wie viele smarties passenden einen
smart
[Musik]
ich will sagen 7 millionen
wenn ich nach diesem rennen jetzt nicht
den ersten platz belegen dann lass video
einfach vorbei sein der auf den dritten
platz
[Musik]
2000 vor